عاش طفوله بائسه قبل ان ينتش له النظام
السوفياتي ويضعه في اهم اجهزه الدوله
الى خائن يقدم خدمات هائله للمخابرات
الغربيه
الجاسوس الذي لم يتهم بالخيانه فقط بل
اوصف بالجاسوس الذي اسقط الدوله باكملها
فما قصته ولد فيروز
عام
1932 في موسكو لعائله متواضعه الحال وكان
ابوه جنديا سابقا وعاملا يعرف بالنزاهه
والمثابره في عمله اما امه فكانت تعمل
خادمه اثناء طفولته كان رياضيا ومتفوقا في
الدراسه وهو ما جعله يختار دراسه الهندسه
الالكترونيه التي كانت بوابه له لد سلك
الاستخبارات السوفيتيه في عام
ونظرا لتميزه تم تعيينه ضابطا مسؤولا عن
برنامج اكس لاين المخصص للحصول على
معلومات متقدمه حول العلوم والتكنولوجيا
من الدول الغربيه وارسل على اثر هذه
المهمه الى فرنسا في عام
حيثما كت خمسه اعوام هنا في الستينيات من
القرن الماضي وبفضل فيتو تحصل برنامج لاين
اكس على معلومات مهمه حول التطورات
العسكريه والتكنولوجيه والصناعيه
جزءا من جسم الدوله السوفيتي ومن اشد
المدافعين عن الاشتراكيه حتى اكثر من
الاشتراكين انفسهم لكن هذه الاعتقادات لم
تدوم طويله فبعد عودته الى بلاده ومع مرور
الزمن اي قناه الجاسوس بيتي ان الدوله
اصبحت مرتاعا للفساد والوسطات وشعر
بالاحباط بين ليله وضحاها تحول ابن الدوله
المخلص الى عدو بثوب رجل دوله ففكر في
الانتقام من النظام الذي قويت كتفه من
خيره فاتصل بالمخابرات الفرنسيه وفتح بابا
كبيرا للتعاون مع الفرنسيين ضد بلاده
رحبت المخابرات الفرنسيه بالعميل الخائن
وتم تجنيده تحت الاسم الرمزي فارويل الذي
عرف به لدى جميع اجهزه مخابرات النيتو بين
عامي
2981 و 2982
اعطى بتروبا المخابرات الفرنسيه ما يقرب
من اربعه الاف وثيقه سريه بما في ذلك
قائمه تضم 250 جاسوسا سوفييتيا كانوا
يعملون في السفارات حول العالم
مكنه الدول الغربيه من طرد ما كروب ومن
150 جاسوسا سوفيتيا فترض الفرنسيون 47
منهم معظمهم من برنامج اكس لاين ما تسبب
في انهيار برنامج المعلومات السوفيتي في
وقت كان فيه بالغ الاهميه للنظام السوفيتي
بدورها انشات الولايات المتحده عمليه ضخمه
لتزويد سوفيه ببيانات خاطئه واجزاء مدمره
لتقنيات معينه
خشيه اكتشافه جمدت المخابرات الفرنسيه
نشاطه بشكل مؤقت لكنه وقع في مصيبه كبرى
عندما طعن شريكته اثناء مشاده كلاميه في
سيارته
وبالمصادفه ترك رجل نافذه السياره فاعتقد
بيتروف انه اكتشف جرينته فقام بطعان الرجل
وقتله ليصادف ان يكون ضابطا اخر من
المخابرات سوفييتيه فعتقل وحكم عليه
بالسجن اثني عشر عاما في خليفه عام 1982
اثناء وجوده في السجن كشف فيترو في رسائل
انه متورط في شيء كبير قبل ذهابه الى
السجن فعرفت المخابرات السوفيتيه في
النهايه انه عميل مزدوج وكجزء من اعترافه
كتب بيتروف رساله لاذعه للنظام السوفيتي
تحت عنوان
اعتراف الخائن
من يناير لعام
1985 اعدم بيتروف برصاصه في راسه داخل
السجن وهو في الخمسين ولكن قبل ان يتم
اعدامه قال للمحققين
انتم ترون كيف انني جاسوس الكبير فيما لم
يعلم انه لم يكون مجرد جاسوس بل كان عمله
بمثابه الضربه القاضيه للجهاز الذي احتضنه
طويل